foreign
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist Chuck
we got an explainer today yes it's an
explainer but we're explaining stuff
that I don't have expertise in okay so
we bring on an expert
how good of us today we're talking about
El Nino ah with a good friend of Star
Talk Catherine hey ho Catherine welcome
back to Star talk thank you for having
me I'd love your title let me get it
right here Chief scientist of the nature
conservative conservancy and
distinguished professor at Texas Tech
University you're an atmospheric
scientist and that's how we've tapped
your expertise in the past and you you
specialize in focusing on how climate
change can infect people end the planet
I mean what else would you want an
atmospheric scientist to do if not that
and you lead and coordinate scientific
efforts at the nature conservancy and I
think Texas Tech you gave you a new
moniker your United Nations champion of
the earth nice We Are the Champions yeah
did you get a belt with that did you get
like a big giant joke
no I will Champion right Captain Marvel
Cape was what I was going for and they
did not deliver oh yeah they they fell
through on that one so Catherine to this
day
if someone asked me what is El Nino I
would have no way to ex I don't I don't
know
so can you just put me in the same place
you are and presumably Chuck and Chuck
is or maybe Chuck is already there Chuck
you know what El Nino is
um um I know what El Chapo is
I know I know El Chapo El Chapo in
prison El Chapo okay
look Catherine just start what is El
Nino other than the literal Spanish
translation of the The Boy Child well
you're very fortunate here because not
only am I an atmospheric scientist I'm
also fluent in Spanish
El Nino refers to the Christ child and
the reason why this mode of natural
variability in the climate system is
called El Nino is because it would
typically manifest in the winter around
Christmas time off the coast of Peru
hence the Spanish connection look at
that yes so it is
uh well I'll tell you what it has to do
with Jesus we are screwed and we need to
become a Jesus moment we need to pray we
need to come to Jesus moment okay Lord
please
Jesus please help us Lord help us okay
100 that is absolutely right no no I
don't believe that no so tell me why
because when I when I see uh Renaissance
paintings uh Madonna and baby it's uh
Madonna and Bambino but I guess that's
Italian not Spanish right yeah Spanish
is El Nino the Christ child that's what
they call you El Nino but now you know
this Neil when when when Jesus was
reputably reputedly born was Christmas
December 25th but we now know
astronomically that it was likely not in
December it is so not in December that
was done it was a pagan it was an
attempt to gather all the Pagan uh uh uh
uh Solstice rituals and replace it with
a Christian ritual to not to piss off
the pagans who you're trying to convert
so yeah it has very little to do with
whatever he would have what part of the
year he would have been born I think
some estimates put it in the spring but
well one of the things that says uh that
the one of the Angel visitations that
Shepherds were tending their flock
exactly right exactly that was not
something that would have happened in
December so even in the scripture itself
it kind of uh betrays the fact that it
wasn't uh what we would call Christmas
tree so why is it named after Jesus baby
well it's named after the Christ child
because it would typically be ramping up
around Christmas time off the coast of
Peru
[Music]
so it's not just off of Peru for it to
be named given a Spanish name it was
uh because of the time of year I get it
okay exactly but of course we know that
only affects us all around the whole
world it's just that it was first
noticed and identified there so that's
where the name comes from all right so
we got the the boy Jesus
covered here so now what is El Nino El
Nino is one of the most well-known modes
of natural variability in the climate
system where over time we see these
modes of natural variability where we
have more Heat going from the ocean into
the atmosphere
that's during an El Nino or more Heat
going from the atmosphere back into the
ocean that's the opposite part La Nina
but that's not the only mode of natural
variability we also have the Pacific
decadal oscillation we have the North
Atlantic oscillation but El Nino is the
most well known and it happens every few
years so every few years we go up into
El Nino then we go back into neutral for
a year or two and then we go down into
La Nina typically and then we go back up
to neutral and what that does is it
affects our weather around the world
that's why this matters to us because
when we have all that heat coming from
the ocean into the atmosphere during El
Nino the globe is a little bit hotter
than average and it also affects
tropical regions predominantly as well
as we get a lot of storms along the
coastal area of North America and
they've even showed for example that
civil conflict in tropical countries
tends to increase during El Nino years
because of the impact of El Nino on
weather and the impact of weather on
people's livelihoods in the economy
your livelihoods or just they get pissed
off because they're hot like like if
you're in an airplane and the AC isn't
working people just fight right that's
where all the all those YouTube videos
come from
or real crime statistics that crime goes
up when we have hotter Summers like the
crime statistics show that there's a
increase in in violence in violence uh
so yeah all right so so but it it comes
off of Peru why would it affect the
whole world why I mean I don't get it
well it's actually a long tongue of warm
water that reaches almost entirely
across the Pacific
so it has a huge impact on Australia as
well and it isn't just temperature it
changes rainfall patterns so some places
during and Downing you get drier and
other places get wetter so it's a great
example of what I like to call Global
weirding things just get weird but then
you superimpose this natural variability
on top of the long-term warming Trend
caused by human emissions of heat
trapping gases and that's when we get a
year like this year
year 2023 where we have excessive heat
in many places across the globe
in the northern hemisphere so so how
long does El Nino last
um El Nino typically lasts it's it's
defined first of all as when sea surface
temperature off the coast of Peru in a
box they call the Nino 3.4 box when sea
surface temperature is more than half
degree above the long-term average and
so it typically lasts for a number of
months
um and then it goes back down into
neutral conditions sometimes it can last
for up to a year
so I've heard people say this year El
Nino is expected to be pretty bad is
that just is that just click bait or is
there extra information or is the Box
bigger than we'd like it I know right
right
well they they do forecast
Nino and the further it departs from the
average the stronger it is and the
greater its effects
so that's what we're looking at this
year is a greater departure from the
neutral condition or the long-term
average but again it's on top of this
long-term warming Trend so we've got two
things going on now we've got El Nino
which often produces chaotic and very
harmful weather especially in along the
west coast of the US and in tropical
areas but then we've got the long-term
warming trend on top of it it's like a
one-two punch and together they're
adding up to greater than some of the
parts
how long when was El Nino first named
that's a great question I'm not sure
about that so I mean are there is there
records in the 1800s 1700s or is it a
19th century 20th century uh invention
um it was recognized by people in Peru
for some time that's why it was already
named by them by the time scientists got
a hold of it scientists they just used
their name yes exactly so it's a great
example if you have people notice things
just the Peruvian civilization was just
like oh look at this it's it's it's
hotter we have this different uh weather
trends they just look looked at it is
that because they were agrarian society
or what what what it would have had to
have happened after the Conquistadors
because there was no Christianity until
Spain arrived in South America
well done well played right I've been
calling it something else and haven't
renamed you need to have an
archaeologist or Anthropologist on after
me to talk about that the coast of Peru
is very dry dry
and so I would assume it had a lot to do
with rainfall patterns and I'm sure that
people living there notice that every
few years their rainfall patterns
shifted dramatically and they probably
did have a name for it but then you're
right they probably whatever it was got
called El Nino after the Conquistadors
arrived yeah now scientists have only
been tracking it we track it on a on a
monthly basis and we've only been
tracking on Nino since the 1950s so we
have records of El Nino variability the
sea surface temperature in that area
going back to the 1950s okay so now what
happened with La Nina what happens
so it's a natural cycle which means it
goes up and down and up and down
and when it goes down that's a lot Nina
so the down part is what temperature
difference what how would you Quantum
it's the same it's more than half a
degree celsius below the long-term
average below the average okay yes
and what does this mean if because since
these Cycles are just always in play
um what does this mean overall when it
comes to what we see with respect to
climate change the climate crisis itself
yes the West is the Pacific did they see
more storms what do they call them
Cyclones in the in the Pacific like when
how does someone brace for this other
than it being maybe higher temperature
than usual
well interestingly it's just a natural
cycle is the number one objection that
people have when they don't want to say
that it's humans causing climate to
change but natural cycles go up and down
so natural cycles get warmer and cooler
and warmer and cooler that's like El
Nino and La Nina but human cause climate
change just gets warmer and warmer and
warmer and warmer and warmer so when
people say it's just a natural cycle I
say oh well what natural cycle is it and
no one really has an answer because we
know that natural cycles like El Nino go
up and down and up and down and so what
they do is these Cycles have something
that we call teleconnections and that is
just basically a fancy word for how this
tongue of warm water off the coast of
Peru affects weather around the world
and scientists have been able to put
that together and we know for example
that we are going to see over Australia
we're going to see dry conditions during
El Nino which is not good news for
Australia because you remember the
terrible wildfires yeah exactly
how oceans had tongues this is an
interesting anatomical feature
it's just anthropomorphized Neil it just
looks like a tongue so in some
temperature map there's a there's this
this tongue
the Gene Simmons of climate I got you oh
yeah it's a Gene Simmons length tongue
okay
all right so so in La Nina does that
mean people actually experience colder
temperatures than usual
average temperature tends to be a bit
below average during a la nina but a lot
of the big impacts come not as much
through temperature but through rainfall
so like I said during El Nino it's very
dry in Australia and it's wetter across
the Southern United States whereas
during a la nina it is very dry in
California New Mexico Arizona Texas and
it's really wet up in the Pacific
Northwest there's like this dipole
effect where it's drier here wetter here
so these affect
um the storms affect you know flooding
they affect landslides they affect the
safety of people's homes the droughts
affect wildfires and crop yields they
have profound impacts on all parts of
our lives and again they're being when
we see this natural variability on top
of that long-term warming Trend that's
when the impacts really add up so Kevin
I have a sort of moral question so
suppose in the coming decades we have
the power
to manipulate
La Nina El Nino and control the severity
of the up and down of it or possibly
even flatten it entirely separate from
the ever Rising temperatures that we're
creating from our own forces of climate
change what I'm asking is if we had the
power to do that
should we
or is this so natural to Earth that the
elements of the Continental shelves or
the oceans that actually want this that
there's some equilibrium in that
variation long-term equilibrium that it
needs it and wants it and seeks it out
that is a very interesting question and
to be honest I don't even know how you
would start to control a natural cycle
I've heard a lot of people talk about
engineering the planet engineering yeah
geoengineering yeah yeah no but this is
very hypothetical so I'm just wondering
does the planet forget us yeah does the
planet benefit from this does it move
fishes where they need to be is there
some uh uh is there a place that gets
rain that wouldn't have otherwise gotten
rain and so there are plants thriving
there that's kind of what I'm asking yes
so so hypothetically we would not want
to do that because natural cycles are
part of how the planet balances its heat
so if there's been too much heat
building up in the ocean an El Nino gets
rid of some of that heat and pushes it
into the atmosphere if there's too much
in the atmosphere it gets rid of it by
pushing it into the ocean so natural
cycles are a little bit like a
teeter-totter or a seesaw they balance
out the heat in the climate these are
regulating forces yes
because without it if you took it away
the ocean could just keep getting hotter
and hotter
and then we we have steamed fish so yeah
and speaking of that seeing as as we are
and by the way now I'm hungry
um no so
since El Nino pushes the heat from the
ocean into the atmosphere
what does it say about the fact that
we're seeing record temperatures in
water temperatures around
many places the Gulf of Mexico 100
degrees we've seen the failure of coral
reefs all at once and normally when that
happens there are several indicators
that could be making that possible but
what they know now is basically they
fried like it was a catastrophe I
thought Catherine so Catherine is it is
it unusually warm temperatures that are
bad for Coral I thought there was an
acidification as well that affects the
corals is certification affects them but
the biggest and soonest impact is from
high temperatures it causes them to
bleach and they can be harmed and
eventually die so what we're seeing is
to transfer heat from the ocean to the
atmosphere the surface of the ocean has
to warm because that's where the heat
transfer occurs oh gotcha so that's why
we're seeing surface temperatures reach
record warm temperatures especially like
I said off the coast of Peru all the way
across the Pacific because that's how
the heat transfer happens but there's
more going on right now
so for the last five four or five months
scientists have been tracking record
high temperatures across the Atlantic as
well and the Atlantic is not where El
Nino happens El Nino happens in the
Pacific right so what's going on is
we've got a couple of different things
so we obviously have long-term
human-caused warming we also have a lot
of dust transport from the Sahara we had
the volcanic eruption hap that happened
this past year and and then we've got El
Nino changing the weather patterns and
the circulation patterns so we've got
one two three four things just adding
stacking up on top of each other and
that's why we're seeing record warm
temperatures not just in the Pacific but
over in the Atlantic as well and like
you were saying Chuck it was hot tub
temperatures off the coast of Florida
this past week Catherine so I can
summarize your last minute of commentary
by saying we're all gonna die
just to have you have you add up all
these phenomena together I mean that
sounds
I mean so what are we going to do we
move to Mars like give me give me say
something positive stop burning fossil
fuels there you go how about this let's
start with what we all can do did I I
didn't ask you
what
he's right so I added up all these
blocks and it is really hard to change
the impact of a volcano or dust from the
Sahara El Nino but the biggest block at
the bottom is us and that block is 100
under human control and that is why it
shouldn't be I shouldn't be telling them
to shut up
oh man well uh uh in in the words of
Neil we are all gonna die
uh I just want to say that it has been a
pleasure serving with you guys and
here's our final broadcast
this is where uh I just pull out my
violin and let's start and just before
we before we close uh Catherine there's
I understand there's climate week coming
up in New York City is that correct
there is climate week and let me tell
you is that every year climate weekend
at the United Nations it does and
there's lots of events that you can
listen to online no matter where you are
and 90 of what people will be talking
about there is what we can do to cut our
carbon emissions invest in nature get
back on track because it is past time to
put these Solutions into action because
we're only doomed if we decide we are
okay all I care about is if heads or
states are here it blocks my traffic
flow here
spoken like a true New Yorker
you're trying to solve The World's
problems I'm trying to get home from my
exactly wait why can't we solve those
problems in Jersey because why do we
have to solve these problems in
Manhattan in Midtown Manhattan seriously
come on
well okay and what role do you have in
the in climate week
I'm going to be speaking at the opening
ceremony and then I'll be doing events
around the city and again there's so
much online that you can listen to and
let me tell you when opening ceremony
you're Marching In With Flags like in
the Olympics what do you mean opening
ceremony if they gave me a Canada flag I
would carry it but oh okay
but speaking about why it's so important
that we all get together and do
something about this because we can
still do something we are not all gonna
die but we have to make that choice
today right okay yeah all right well
we'll look we'll look for you in the in
the video Recaps of uh and we're
delighted that you you're not only a
scientist that you have a voice that uh
is out there trying to make a difference
in the world and not every scientist has
that privilege really and so it's a
testament to the fact that when you
speak people want to listen
when you speak people understand what
you're saying yeah there you go how
about that
I admit I admit I went slightly before
mode of natural variability but but
hopefully that was the only technical
part
well Catherine Hale thanks for being
back on start talk for this explainer on
El Nino and La Nina Chuck always good to
have you man always a pleasure this is
Neil deGrasse Tyson closing out our
explainer on climate
as always keep looking up
foreign
[Music]